we also are following some new  guidelines today released from the cdc  it is relaxing rules about wearing a  mask outside  if you are fully vaccinated fully  vaccinated means two weeks after you  receive your second dose  so here are the changes you can gather  in small groups outside without wearing  a mask if everyone in that group is  fully vaccinated  you can also eat outside at a restaurant  without a mask  health and human services secretary  javier becerra  says the mask mandate will stay in place  for certain public places  we want to get back to a normal  lifestyle we want to get our economy  going people back at work  restaurants open you got to do that the  right way and masks help  vaccinations important masks help and so  even though i'm  i've been vaccinated i still wear a mask  nearly 40 percent of u.s adults are now  fully vaccinated  and the number of new covet cases  nationally is down 14 percent  from the previous week